angenommen ich möchte
reinkommen wie muss ich mich verhalten
wie muss ich sein und was erwartet mich
da also auf jeden Fall ohne Murren die
nötigen Schulterklappen sammeln die
Schulterklappen sammelt man durch one
nighter oder
tighter One nighter ist wenn Sie eine
Nacht im Büro schlafen ein T nighter ist
wenn Sie zwei Nächte im Büro schlafen
bzw durch
arbeiten wenn Sie das dann genug gemacht
haben dann kommt irgendwann schon jemand
auf die Idee sie mit größeren Aufgaben
zu
betrauen aber nur dann wenn sie nicht
den kleinsten Anschein des Zweifels
erwecken oder auch nur
andeutungsweise formulieren dass es
vielleicht ein paar Sachen gibt die man
anders machen könnte Schrägstrich
sollte politische Äußerung bloß nicht
und ja bedingungslose Loyalität GEG der
Organisation sie müssen bereit sein ihr
Leben aufzugeben
letztenendes wie läuft so ein Tigh
ab na ja da kommt der Chef zu Ihnen und
sagt pass mal auf ich habe hier was auf
den Tisch gekriegt wir müssen übermorgen
bei Firma XY Z Konzept präsentieren mit
mit welcher Finanzierung die 10% iher
Aktien zurück ü kaufen können und eine
Einschätzung wie das auf dem Markt wirkt
und so weiter und so
weiter tut mir leid ich weiß du hast
heute Geburtstag und wolltest heute
Abend mit deiner Freundin essen gehen
aber ich habe keine Ahnung wem ich das
sonst geben kann dann ist am
Sack dann setzt er sich hin und macht
seine Powerpoints und nachts um z
schläft dann im Schreibtisch ein und um
5R wird auf noch kurz vor gewckt und
dann geht's
weiter nicht hinterfragen ob das Sinn
macht dass das Unternehmen diese Aktien
zurückkauft ganz blöde
Idee es ist letzten Endes wie bei der
[Musik]
Armee
Sch
[Musik]
derüen
eer
lass
l
gch
l nicht
deine
[Musik]
er
wasicher
Freund also ich habe noch mal mit dem
Anwalt gesprochen und so wie er das
einschätzt DF es eigentlich so lange
kein Problem sein
solange keinen Namen genannt werden oder
Geschäftsgeheimnisse also wenn wieder
Persönlichkeitsrechte noch Datenschutz
verletzt werden also ich würde
vorschlagen dass sie noch mal mit dem
Anwalt Rücksprache halten auch was die
Arbeitsverträge betrifft die Klauseln
die dort enthalten sind so dass wir da
auf der sicheren Seite
sind
[Musik]
da hinten das Gebäude mit der runden mit
dem
runden Turm oben drauf wo man noch wenn
man sich das ein bisschen visualisiert
man sieht diese weiße Scheibe oben
unterhalb der beiden Fenster rein wenn
sich das visualisiert da war mal das
Logo der
Citybank das war die Zentrale der
Citybank dann war Mary lych drin auf 20
Etagen dann irgendwann Blomberg
und heute ist die Bank of communication
aus China da drin und ich glaube sonst
nicht
viel ja dann haben wir
hier kann man sehr schön den Sprung der
Kommerzbank sehen dieses Gebäude mit dem
grünen Dach ist meines Wissens das
ursprüngliche Gebäude gewesen von der
Kommerzbank in Frankfurt dann kam der
erste Turm den sieht man da in diesem
dunkelbraun zwischen den beiden zwischen
dem japantauer und dem taunusturm dieses
Stück und direkt dahinter tront
dann das neue und aktuelle Gebäude der
Kommerzbank wo man Antenne drauf gesetzt
hat damit zu ist das von der Deutschen
Bank das sieht mir aus als hätte das der
Trading Flor sein sollen das s die
serverrexs das ist halt sehr sch das
wenn das ein trading floor werden sollte
was ich glaube dann ist das wirklich
kleiner also ein Trading idealer
tradingfow hat überhaupt keine Wende
möglichst auch nicht solche Säulen
sondern ist einfach wie ein Fußballfeld
durchgehend ohne jede
Begrenzung früher war man noch mehr auf
so auf mündliche Kommunikation
angewiesen da musste man sich zurufen
und das deswegen war das wichtig dann
sind die Leute Hal von den Tischen
aufgestanden und dann konnte man sich
sehen auf 20 oder 25 m mit Handzeichen
oder mit mit Rufen irgendwelche
irgendwelche Sachen klären heute alles
heute gibt's halt so kleine Chatrooms in
denen man sich dann unterhalten kann da
muss man nicht mehr
rumbrüen die Training FL von den ganz
großen Banken als ich glaube der größte
ist in greenage von der UBS zumindest
gewesen die haben glaub ich 1000
Positionen also 1000 Leute auf einer
Fläche weiß nicht was hier reingeht 100
vielleicht wenn
überhaupt das ist so ein bisschen wie
wie das allereiligst oder so ja da
kommst Du halt durch durch so
Sicherheitsschleusen rein und dann gehst
an deinen Platz und dann drückst du so
ein Knopf und dann
[Musik]
macht und
dann kommt der Nachbar und dann sagst du
guten Morgen dann drückt der auf seinen
Knopf
mach
irgendwann sind dann alle da und dann
nimmt die ganze Sache Fahrt
auf und so ab 90 steigt dann der
Lärmpegel ja das ist wie wie auf eine
Steuerzentrale vom Raumschiff Enterprise
oder so ich weiß das klingt jetzt total
bekloppt aber man man man fühlt sich
schon al es ist im Prinz so so die Zutat
um sich so als als Master of Universe zu
fühlen man sitzt in so einem in so einem
sehr bequemen Sessel dann hat man da
dieses halbrund von Schirmen das sind
sechs oder acht Bildschirme die man da
hat und da Flimmern lustige Sachen und
dann hat man zwei Tastaturen und Telefon
und eine Maus oder zwei Mäuse und kann
dann da so ist ist
so es ist nichts für jeden aber also ich
fand das ziemlich faszinierend muss ich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sagen
[Musik]
bei 86 war das Thatcher und regagon die
haben im Prinzip die ersten
privatisierungswellen losgetreten und
hier in Deutschland war das
ein ganz kuscheliger
Kapitalmarkt zo vorher wo letztenendes
alles durchreguliert war dann wurden die
Auslandsbanken zugelassen in Deutschland
ja und dann kamen diese Menschen aus
Amerika von denen wir Anfang alle
glaubten die könnten über Wasser laufen
die hatten alle so komische
Hosenträger breitgestreifte Hemden und
haben uns mal erklärt wie die Welt so
funktioniert das war faszinierend man
wurden dann auf Seminare geschickt da
hab die dann dann erklärt wie wie Swaps
funktionieren wie Optionen funktionieren
wie Finanzinnovation das war damals so
der das das geflügelte Wort
Finanzinnovationen funktionieren wir
haben ihren Lippen gehangen und haben
gedacht das sind gottgleiche Wesen die
uns da geschickt
werden ja und dann hat man dann
angefangen diese ganzen Instrumente auch
in Deutschland zuzulassen was nicht also
ich sag das mal ganz ausdrücklich was
nicht
schlecht war weil das
war ein sehr anachronistisches System
das wir hatten ein sehr abgeschlossenes
mit speziellen regionalen
Eigenheiten das taugte nicht um um eine
Wirtschaft ins 21 Jahrhundert zu
begleiten son hat im Prinzip die
Realwirtschaft und die Finanzwirtschaft
auf Augenhöhe gebracht technisch na ja
und dann ist halt die Finanzwirtschaft
der Realwirtschaft
vorausgelaufen das ist die Situation die
wir jetzt heute
haben war die Deregulierung dafür
verantwortlich nein war sie
Voraussetzung ja
dann bin ich da wari ja damals eine
bayerische Bank dann bin ich wochenlang
in die Provinz gefahren ist die
tschechische Grenze was weiß ich wo ich
überall war haben wir dann Vorträge
gehalten haben halt so versucht dann
unsere Produktpalette zu
erweitern ich glaube auf Seiten der
Empfänger war die Freude über mein
kommen doch relativ
verhalten kann sich das vielleicht auch
vorstellen jetzt speziell in dem
regionalen Kontext das haben wir immer
schon so gemacht gell da will man nicht
mit solchen neuen Sachen dann irgendwie
zu tun kriegen und ich habe den Leuten
nur immer gesagt WIS ihr seid hier weit
weg von Frankfurt ihr seid auch weit weg
von London das heißt aber nicht dass
hier keiner hinkommt sondern das heißt
nur dass es länger
dauert ich war ja zu der Zeit noch keine
30 ja das war natürlich eine Sache wo
man sich innerhalb der Bank unheimlich
profilieren konnte schon in jungen
Jahren weil es ein Herrschaftswissen war
dass dann außer das gab gab es in der
Bank vielleicht 10 oder 15 Leute die die
sich mit dem Zeug auskannten ja und wenn
man da einer von war
dann spielte auch das Alter keine Rolle
mehr dann war man halt der Experte und
wurde auch als solche angesehen egal wie
alt oder wie doof man war ja nein es war
das das war eine Möglichkeit sehr
schnell zu
großer Berühmtheit zu gelangen sozusagen
in der in der Bank
ne ja das dir
gelungen das müssen andere
beurteilen das kann ich nicht sagen aber
du wurdest in jungen Jahren ich bin ich
bin ich bin in jungen Jahren sehr
schnell befördert worden ich habe auch
sehr schnell immer mehr Geld verdient
das ist
klar gab's andere bei denen das
schneller ging ja gab's viele bei denen
es langsamer ging auch
ja wir waren ja eine ganze Kohorte von
Leuten in meiner Altersklasse und wir
sind durch diese diese Banken
durchgerollt es war letztenendes so dass
viele von den älteren Mitarbeitern halt
doch eine Menge Fähigkeiten hatten aber
die hatten keine Lust mehr sich mit
Computern zu beschäftigen während ich
mich noch erinnern kann dass wir
wirklich nächtelang gesessen haben und
haben versucht irgendwelche Excel
spreadsheets zu programmieren
irgendwelche Rechenmodelle für
irgendwelche Finanzinstrumente sowas ja
das war eine Industrie das ist wie das
war wie wie Bill Gates mit seiner scheiß
Garage
ja du der 5 Jahre vorher oder 5 Jahre
später hätte der Mann heute wird der man
heute wahrscheinlich irgw als Buchhalter
arbeiten aber der war zur richtigen Zeit
in dieser verdammten
Garage und wir waren halt damals
zufällig da als zufällig auch die
Computer kamen und wir haben uns
zufällig für Computer interessiert und
zufällig
für ja für für Bücher englische Bücher
über Finanztheorie
z.B das war im Prinzip wie so eine g
gtische Sandkiste ja in der man damit
seinen Förmchen spielte wir konnten
damals nichts kaputt machen ne heute
kann in der Sandkiste verdammt viel
kaputt gehen selbst wenn wir gewollt
hätten hätten wir damals nichts kaputt
machen können wir fanden das Klass wir
irgendwas Neues ausgedacht irgendwelche
verrückten Produkte ich habe mal ölbonds
erfunden ne wo es keine Zinsen gibt
sondern
Heizöl die hingen davon ab oder da war
der Ölpreis ich sag mal irgendeine Zahl
30 $ und ich habe da ein richtiges
Papier zugeschrieben alles
aufgeschrieben wie die konstruiert sein
müssten und so weiter und ausgestattet
und wie man den hedge macht und so
weiter und so weiter und dann dann sagte
mein Chef zu mir was das Kannen sie
vergessen so ein Schwachsinn das da muss
ja da muss ja erstmal muss ja Krieg im
Irak sein
und dann muss der Ölpreis ja so
exorbitant explodieren bevor das Zeug
jemand kauft das war glaube ich vier
Tage bevor der Hus in den kuvit
einmarschiert ist äh das fand ich dann
wieder ganz
[Musik]
witzig
e
[Musik]
know that
woulded that theyed to Inv they don't
know you tell you thought it
was
take
166e
2607 je 22 ju 1 2007 salesce toior wol
toior
A l of it that
date trying sitt de well can
you that yes or no arees in market that
people Inv in things I didn't use that
ter with respect
to Daniel sp
know longes
Anw refusal to give answers the long
delays those anwers but it's not to work
we're goingna stay here as long as it
takes to get this inform
the
ich kann ih ganz einfaches Beispiel
machen das sind Zinswetten die sind
massiv verkauft worden an Gemeinden und
an mittelständische Unternehmen und es
ist eine Wette auf die Veränderung der
Zinskurve zwischen Schweizer Franken und
Jen
und das ist ja nur mal eine Position wo
mal deutsche Gemeinde gar nichts mehr zu
tun
hat keiner wettet auf irgendwas was
offensichtlich ist weil da würde man
wahrscheinlich nichtmals einen finden
der mit einem wettet aber manchmal geben
Halt diese Modelle die die Banken
benutzen
Situationen heraus die sehr ungewöhnlich
sind
im englischen hat sich für sowas der
Ausdruck Black Swan rausgebildet
schwarzer Schwan also wie wie groß ist
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass jetzt gleich
auf diesem See hier in schwarzer Schwan
vorbeigeschwommen kriegt unheimlich
gering und diese Situationen zu
identifizieren ist mal der erste Schritt
so jetzt müssen noch ein paar andere
Dinge zusammenkommen um so ein Produkt
verkaufen zu können man könnte z.B diese
Konstruktion niemals einer Firma
verkaufen wie z.B Volkswagen oder BMW
weil die haben dieselben Modelle wie die
Banken würden die Parameter dieser
Gleichung eingeben und wären auf
derselben Seite wie die Bank das wäre
dann unsere wette dass die Sonne morgen
aufgeht die wir beide nicht eingehen
würden weil wir beide meinen dass morgen
die Sonne aufgeht das heißt Sie können
so ein Produkt nur an einen Kunden
verkaufen dem diese Möglichkeiten nicht
offen
stehen das zweite was man sagen muss
ist und das ist eine ganz wichtige
Einschränkung diese Produkte machen für
bestimmte Kunden
Sinn das heißt es gibt Kunden auf der
Welt die Position in ihrer Bilanz
haben die ein Risiko enthalten dass ich
mit dieser Konstruktion neutralisieren
kann das ist halt so als würden sie auf
ehhaus eine feuerschutzversicherung
abschließen und jetzt kommt die
spannende Frage schließe ich auf mein
Haus eine feuerschutzversicherung ab
oder schließe ich eine
feuerschutzversicherung auf das Haus
meines Nachbarn an was ich damit sagen
will ist das Produkt macht nur dann Sinn
wenn es für mich eine entsprechende
Gegenposition gibt ansonsten ist es
Spekulation ist den Kunden überhaup klar
was sie da kaufen nein das ist halt
genau die Schweinerei ja das will ich
jetzt nicht aufgezeichnet haben bitte äh
im Ernst
ja noch mal noch mal zurück
das die ich wäre mich ich wäre mich
gegen diese stark simplifizierte
Vorstellung dass da kriminelle Elemente
am Werk sind die sich irgendwelche Dinge
überlegen um andere Leute übers Ohr zu
hauen wir reden hier nicht über
albanische hütenspieler sondern wir
reden darüber dass Produkte existieren
die auf der einen Seite Sinn machen und
auf der anderen Seite falsch angewandt
Unheil anrichten
können ich versuche einfach mal diese
ganze Sache weiterzus Spinnen um es
vielleicht noch deutlicher zu machen wie
solche Mechanismen funktionieren ja da
gibt's diesen einen kamerer der hat
dieses Geschäft abgeschlossen eine Woche
später ist Kammerer Kongress in Dortmund
da treffen die sich sagt immer ihr seid
eigentlich ganz schön bescheuert wisst
wie eure Defizite wegkriegt in der
kommunalbilanz Schweiz Franken gegen Jen
habe ich gemacht lege ich 3 Millionen
vorne so war das ja am Anfang liege ich
3 Millionen
vorne Bürgermeister super ja dann halten
sich ja alle anderen die um Tisch sitzen
für die letzten Deppen so zeitgleich
findet eine bankentagung statt wo sich
derivatehändler über neue Produkte
austauschen sag ein ich habe der einen
stad ein Ding angenagelt riesig 800 000
habe ich gemacht an dem Ding ein
Trade sitzen die Bänker da und halten
sich auch alle für bescheuert muss ich
jetzt noch erklären was passieren wird
mehr Banken werden das Produkt anbieten
mehr Kamera werden das dening Kaufen
Lemminge ja aber das auch das das ist
alles menschlich das ist nicht das ist
nicht Perfidie das ist nicht das ist
nicht
Täuschung mag es Fälle gegeben haben wo
Täuschung im Spiel war ja natürlich dann
werden ja auch solche Leute die so ein
Geschäft abgeschlossen haben die werden
dann natürlich auch von der Bank wieder
eingeladen um vor anderen Kunden zu
sprechen natürlich klar das ist
miteinander verwoben und und normal das
ist der der würd es würde es heute diese
Klagen geben wenn die Geschichte
andersrum ausgegangen wäre und die
Gemeinde hät 30 Millionen eingesagt ich
habe da meine Zweifel
ja
diese 10 Jahre und bei dieser zweiten
Bank wo ich war das war eine richtig
tolle Zeit wir hatten einen eindeutigen
Gegner also ein konkurrenzinstitut und
es diente einer Sache die zwischen uns
unausgesprochen ganz klar war wir wollen
Geschäft machen das bisher andere Leute
machen und wir wollen es besser
machen also man hat jetzt z.B lange
lange gekämpft um einen Deal zu bekommen
von der Firma da chemical in USA um für
die eine Anleihe platzieren zu dürfen
von 500 Millionen Euro mit Ihnen
zusammen hab natürlich auch ganze
Konkurrenz gekämpft keiner weiß wer
gewonnen
dann kriegen sie den Anruf und dann muss
das vorbereitet werden ohne dass es
rauskommt sie müssen bestimmte
sicherungsoptionen machen sie müssen
ihre Verkäufer informieren dass bald
diese Anleihe zu verkaufen ist und dann
sitzen sie da und drücken auf den Knopf
und dann erscheint dieser Deal in diesen
ganzen Nachrichtensystem und dann
stellen Sie sich vor wie sich ganzen
Konkurrenten ärgern wie die zu ihren
Chefs gerufen werden warum haben wir den
Deal nicht bekommen kriegen sie das
Gefühl dass sie mit diesem Knopfdruck
die Weltgeschichte verändert
haben du hast dann halt ein Angebot von
so einer anderen Bank ja und da steht
dann irgendwie drin du verdienst dreimal
so viel und bist viermal so wichtig und
außerdem kannst du deine ganze Familie
mitbringen und die Mieten dir ein Haus
das war ja unglaublich ja und dann gehst
du zu deinem Chef und sagst eigentlich
gefällt mir her ganz gut aber ich muss
Ihnen sagen ich gehe weg und dann wirst
du durch die Mangel gedreht erklärt dir
was man alles vorhat und da und da
könnte deine Rolle sein und plötzlich
tun sich in diesem Kontext in dem man
gedacht hat nichts entwickelt sich ja
tun sich völlig neue Welten auf und dann
ist plötzlich dieses Angebot von den
anderen gar nicht mehr so attraktiv und
ich kann mich erinnern dass ich bei
einem Vorstand speziell im Büro gesessen
habe mit dem habe ich mich sehr sehr gut
verstanden und ich habe geheult in
schlossund ich habe gesagt helfen Sie
mir ich habe keine Ahnung wie ich aus
der Nummer
rauskomme ich ich weiß nicht was ich
machen soll ich habe dem das versprochen
und ich fühle mich ganz schlecht wenn
ich dem jetzt nein sage und ich fühle
mich genauso schlecht wenn ich noch
schlechter wenn ich Ihnen jetzt sage ich
gehe weiß was der gemacht hat der hat
den Hörer genommen hat bei der anderen
Bank
angerufen und hat den gesagt
Jungs das war's lass den man in Ruhe
dann hat er dann hat er gesagt ich soll
jetzt nach Hause gehen meine Frau ich
hatte damals noch keine Kinder meine
Frau ins Auto packen und
wegfahren weil die ganze Nacht würde
mein Telefon
klingeln ich habe gedacht der spinn alle
3 Minuten die ganze Nacht
durch Warter der sah seine Fälle
wegschwimmen weil der kriegt natürlich
eine relativ hohe Provision wenn da
jemand so hohen Gehalt wie
[Musik]
mich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fast 5 Milliarden Euro hat Kiel verzockt
mit 50 Milliarden hatte er teilweise
jongliert angeblich im Glauben seine
Bank wolle es so von ihm die
Vorgesetzten haben mich behandelt wie
eine Prostituierte die immer fette
Gewinne bringen sollte ich musste der
Bank jeden Tag mehr Geld beschaffen mit
dieser Geschichte konnte Jerome kviel
seine Richter in Paris so gar nicht
überzeugen entsprechend hoch heute die
Haftstrafe sein Anwalt
ratlos die Bank wird geschont obwohl Sie
Jerome kviel erst geformt hat in einem
völlig virtuellen System mit maßlosen
Finanzprodukten solange die Händler
Gewinne machen ist alles gut machen sie
Verluste verklagt sie die Bank die ist
hingegen hoch erfreut über das
Urteil die societ general ist zufrieden
dass ihr der Schadensersatz für Ihre
finanziellen Verluste zugesprochen wurde
4,9 Milliarden Euro soll kviel
zurückzahlen wollte er das tun müsste er
bei seinem jetzigen Gehalt als itberater
rund 178 000 Jahre
arbeiten
na ja um die Frage zu beantworten warum
das immer Einzelpersonen
sind das hängt das hängt mit dem auch
damit zusammen mit dem System also ich
glaube auch dass draußen die Leute
überschätzen welche welche Funktion so
ein Händler in diesem Bankensystem
spielt das ist ja keine
Führungskraft ja das ist letzten Endes
chefschrauber am Band von
Daimler ja natürlich haben die Händler
Junior Händler seniorhändler
unterschiedliche Limits das ist völlig
klar aber mir fällt kein anderer Beruf
ein jetzt spontan wo man in so einer
Position solche Schäden verursachen
kann das muss man sich vorstellen wie
eine auf dem Kopf gestellte Pyramide die
die die die Leute die richtig Schaden
anrichten können die sitzen
unten ja also ich hoffe ich hoffe man
versteht das also die ich glaube da ist
auch draußen immer die die Vorstellung
dass das alles Leute sind die sind
äh managing Direktor oder oder haben
also riesen riesen Titel nein das sind
das sind so so ein so ein Händler der
wird gut bezahlt ja aber der hat in dem
Sinne keine der hat keine Verantwortung
außer die für sein begrenzten Bereich
das das sind keine Manager das sind das
sind ja legehänen wenn ich es bös
formulieren
müsste also es ist völlig normal dass
ein handelstisch in so einer Bank ob der
jetzt mit mit Aktien handelt oder mit
Derivaten oder festzlichchen
Wertpapieren so ein handelstisch mit
drei vier Mitarbeitern also ich sag mal
drei Leute plus Assistentin der hat den
Umsatz und den Gewinn von einem
mittelständischen Betrieb mit 100
Angestellten man muss ja auch sich
vorstellen unter welchem Druck die Leute
stehen also diese Analogie ich weiß
nicht ob ich mich zu der Formulierung
versteigen würde aber er spricht ja
selber davon dass er behandelt worden
ist wie eine Prostituierte und er müsste
jedes Jahr mehr Geld reinbringen ja das
das das ist mir aus meiner Praxis auch
bekannt ja das das ist das gibt immer
nur das wird also da wird nicht geguckt
ob ob äh ein bestimmter Markt irgendwas
hergibt oder ob es in diesem Markt
Veränderungen gibt die entweder für eine
bestimmte Zeit oder strukturell dafür
sorgen dass in diesem Markt nicht so
viel Geld verdient werden kann nein das
gibt's nicht da wird jedes Jahr 10% mehr
wie du das machst ist mir egal ja i
don't care how you do it das sind
Sprüche die habe ich
gehört
ich habe eine Zahl gelesen in dem Buch
da wird beschrieben dass vor 20 Jahren
die Haltedauer einer Aktie im
Durchschnitt 4 Jahre war und heute sind
wir bei 22
Sekunden
ja der der also das ist ja schon an sich
wenn man einfach mal drüber nachdenkt
eine Aktie ist ja ein
Unternehmensbeteiligung der der Sinn
eine Unternehmensbeteiligung für 22
Sekunden zu behalten
also das kann mir keiner erklären
ja man versucht irgendwie immer näher an
die an die Rechner der Börsen
ranzukommen weil diese diese sind ja
nichtms wimpernschläge das sind ja
atomzerfallszeiten oder sowas zwischen
diesen
Entfernungen weil die schon den
Unterschied ausmachen zwischen dem
erfolgreichen Deal und dem anderen der
die Information später kriegt das sind
Zeiten die kannst du wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr messen aber trotzdem sind
diese diese 500 m die das die der eine
Rechner näher an dem röchenzentrum der
Börse dran steht als der andere das
macht schon den
Unterschied man muss sich das so
vorstellen dass diese selbstständig
handelnden Computersysteme orders
platzieren Kauf oder Verkaufsorders und
zu gucken wie reagiert wird und dann
diese orders ganz schnell wieder
rausnehmen das heißt da steht nicht die
Absicht hinter Vermögenswert zu handeln
sondern es steht die Absicht dahinter
rauszufinden wie sich der Markt
positioniert halt also gibt's mehr
Käufer oder Verkäufer oder noch
schlimmer den Markt in eine bestimmte
Richtung zu
beeinflussen dadurch dass diese Volumina
so irrsinnig groß sind reichen ja
winzige Preisbewegungen aus um richtig
viel Geld zu
verdienen ja also wenn du jetzt mit
100.000 € irgendwo anfängst rumzumachen
dann brauchst Du ja schon mal 1%
Preisbewegung um 1000 € zu verdienen
aber wenn du mit Milliarden und aber
Milliarden rum machst dann reicht dir
die vier oder fünfte Stelle hinterm
Komma um einen gewissen Gewinn zu
erzielen das ist einfach ein
Ungleichheit der Waffen die spiegelt
sich halt auch in diesem Computersystem
wieder Siemens oder Volkswagen die sind
schlauer als die Bank das kann man
gerade mal lassen ja aber dann geht's
halt runter in Richtung Mittelstand dann
geht's in Richtung Kommunalverwaltung
und in Richtung
Privatkunde das ist ein alter Spruch an
der Börse das im Prinzip die
Privatanleger immer
verlieren klar gewinnen die auch mal
aber das ist so wie beim Roulette ja ein
roulettpieler erinnert sich immer an die
8000 € die er gestern im Casino gewonnen
hat aber die 5 x 2000 die in der Woche
davor verloren hat die hat er vergessen
das ist menschlich ja
also Dauer
dauerhaft dauerhaft
ähm risikolos an der Börse Geld zu
verdienen das ist richtig das ist
richtig
schwierig die Zeit der bescheidenen
Aktienkurse Schnee von gestern alles
zieht und drängt an die Börse im
vergangenen Jahr wurde wiederum ein
Rekordwert erreicht 194 Unternehmen
feierten ihre börsenpremiere ist nicht
so langsam Zeit internig zu ma sind V
allem Firmen aus dem Internet Medien und
Computerbereich mehr als 500% legten
deren Börsenkurse in der Vergangenheit
zu Chef der Mobilkom Schmidt strahlt
sein Unternehmen hat den Sprung in den
Neuen Markt erfolgreich geschafft
Anleger kon ein schn machen wenn Sie die
zum ausgabpreis neue Markt ist das
Wachstumssegment in Deutschland
dementsprechend auch eines der
interessantesten Segmente für ein risik
Michel wir wollen heute ein Thema reden
die Frauen haben es in der Regel am
Ringfinger oder um den Hals wir Männer
eher im Auto wir reden über Platin
Platin sehr schön der Platin Preis war
doch dieses Jahr recht turbulent
unterwegs muss man sagen es ging auf und
ab war ein bisschen
achterbahnfahrtmäßig was erwarten
Analysten so auf Jahresfrist also die
konservativen Schätzungen die gehen so
100 im Durchschnitt im Jahr 2013 00 im
Jahr 2014 gibt auch positivere aber
dasassind so die allgemeinen
konszenschätzung also steigende Preise
jetzt moderat steigende Preise ja das
moderat steigend da ist noch ein
bisschen Platz zum aktuellen Kurs
dementsprechend würdest Du uns auch ein
Hebelprodukt ans Herz legen und hast du
auch schon was ausgesucht was für
Produkte hast du ausgesucht ja wir haben
W unlimited call der hatten im Moment
eine Barriere ungefähr bei 15
15002 die Unze wir sind bei 1620 wie du
sagtest 120 Platz nach unten und ja wie
gesagt das ist so der Vorteil von dem
Produkt wäre halt Laufzeit unbegrenzt
ist und dass der Anleger damit ein
bisschen Zeit hat B das
investmententwickelt genau das heißt das
ist für den Anleger der eher eine
positive Meinung hat für den der
negative hat haben wir natürlich auch
Wave unlimited Putz mehr dazu gibt's
auch auf unserer Webseite
wwwxmars.de vielen dank Michael ein
schönes
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Wochenende
ich komme jetzt nicht aus demem
kosmopolitischen Haushalt und bin dann
nach München gekommen mit meinem Koffer
im Zug das weiß ich noch auf den Bahnhof
gekommen ich kannte in der Stadt
eigentlich keinen ich wusste nur ich
müsste am nächsten
Tag da meinen Dienst
antreten ich sprach rudimentär Englisch
so für ein Hausgebrauch und das war auch
meine einzige Fremdsprache und ich ging
über die Flur und aus dem einen Zimmer
kam Spanisch aus dem anderen Zimmer kam
Französisch aus dem dritten Zimmer kam
eine Sprache die kannte ich nicht und
ich bin da lang gegangen und habe
irgendwie gedacht da möchtest du gerne
dazu
gehören ich habe dann angefangen Bücher
zu lesen
ja Bücher über Wein Bücher über Zigarren
Bücher über Kleidung Bücher über Schuhe
und irgendwann kriegt man dann Gefühl
und irgendwann hat man auch ein
Gesprächspartner mit dem man darüber
reden kann
ja mein Vater ist ein kleiner
heizungsingenieur ich habe vom ersten
Tag als ich anfing zu arbeiten nach dem
Studium mehr Geld verdient als der am
Ende seines Lebens vom ersten Tag an
habe ich als Tokio angerufen oder aus
New York und so und dann habe ich meine
Mutter angerufen ich glaube die hat gar
nicht geglaubt dass ich da bin
[Musik]
ja
du kommst da
morgens rein und eigentlich weißt du was
sich was der Tag so mit sich bringt und
äh es wird für dich gesorgt du hast mit
nichts mehr was zu tun du fährst direkt
von der Straße undten in die
Tiefgarage paar Treppen nach oben ist in
deinem
Arbeitsplatz und du musst dich
eigentlich um die um die Außenwelt nicht
so richtig
kümmern die Kinder gehen denelben
Kindergarten man macht denselben Urlaub
an denselben Orten und fährt nach gestar
zum Ski laaufen oder man fährt auf die
sechellen und Mauritius und dann wird da
Drau so ein geschlossenes System indem
man immer weiter sich von der
Wirklichkeit
entfernt zum einen brauche ich die Welt
da draußen nicht mehr in großen Teilen
und deswegen mache ich mir auch keine
Gedanken en darüber ob das was ich in
meinem in meinem Job mache die Deals die
ich abschließe oder die die die Aktionen
die ich die ich mache ob die
irgendwelche Auswirkungen auf die Welt
da draußen
haben
diese Abkoppelung vom von
gesellschaftlichen Prozess die die ist
quasi
institutionalisiert sie können ja bei
dem bei dem Abendessen überhaupt nicht
über ihren Beruf
reden wenn mir jemand gesagt hat ja wir
fahren jetzt mit TUI in Urlaub und ich
habe jetzt rausgefunden den da ist es
billiger noch mal 200 € das sind Sachen
über die habe ich mir keine Gedanken
gemacht wen so 100.000 im Monat
verdienen ist ihnen das egal ja also sie
haben quasi keine interessensbasis mehr
mit ihren Freunden außer sie zwingen
sich über andere Sachen zu reden aber
ein bestimmter Teil ihres Lebens bleibt
ausgespart oder für die anderen
uninteressant und dann überlegt man halt
ob man ob man eigentlich lieb gewwonnene
Dinge aufgibt für was unsicheres was
vielleicht besser
ist und man müsste jetzt eigentlich wenn
man normal funktioniert müsste man sagen
wenn mein Beruf sowas mit mir macht dann
brauche ich einen neuen Beruf aber keine
neue
Familie aber in dem Beruf habe ich
gedacht der Beruf ist okay ich brauche
dazu eine passen eine neue eine neue
Beziehung wie auch immer man das nennen
möchte
also ich habe große Diskussion mit
meiner Frau gehabt als unser erstes Kind
geboren wurde we meine Frau wollte dass
ich Babyurlaub nehme was auch bei meinem
damaligen Arbeitgeber Anfang der 90er
Jahre möglich gewesen wäre
ich habe immer gesagt es geht nicht
meine Frau hat gesagt du willst nur
nicht das geht nicht du willst nur nicht
es ging
nicht ja
ähm das ist ein bisschen das was ich
vorhin sagte wenn man also man weiß im
Vorhinein wenn man diesen Beruf ausübt
und sich für diesen Beruf entscheidet
dann weiß man im Vorhinein worauf man
sich einlässt und da passt Babyurlaub
nicht ich will nicht ausschließen dass
es Leute gibt die das machen aber das
ich hätte das nicht
gekonnt ich hätte auch das Gefühl gehabt
dass ich dann meinen eigenen Ansprüchen
was die berufliche Seite angeht selber
nicht mehr gerecht werde völlig
abgesehen davon ob es eine Möglichkeit
gegeben hätte das zu machen oder nicht
dazu ist dann doch die
die ich ich denke man merkt das manchmal
wenn man mich erzählt das ist schon ein
Virus der einen packt ja und zu der Zeit
über die wir jetzt reden da war ich
schwerst
infiziert du hast gesagt ich habe
entschieden
mhm gab's auch mal ein
wir
meinst du es jetzt in Bezug auf meine
Familie oder ja ja ja die Situation
gab's auch mal das war aber weniger ein
wir sondern meine Frau hat gesagt wenn
du das machst gehe ich nicht
[Gelächter]
mit was war das ist das war eine
ähnliche Situation da wä um auslandsjob
gegangen ein Ort wo meine Frau nicht hin
wollte
[Musik]
ähm
na ja das ist natürlich auch auch eine
Sache wenn ich jetzt mal drüber
nachdenke noch mal wieder zurück in
diese goldenen Zeiten die ich gerade so
idealisiert habe die vielleicht gar
nicht so die ideal waren im Rückblick
verklärt sich manches da habe ich auch
gelitten teilweise aber lassen wir es
mal einfach so stehen wie ich gerade
erzählt habe das ist natürlich auch so
dass dann
wenn man sag mal wichtiger wird
sozusagen
dann wird auch zunehmend die Familie in
diesen ganzen Kontext eingebunden also
soweit ich weiß geht's bei jeder
größeren Bank die was auf sich hält eine
familienfeiert
z.B ja wo ähm Kinder und und
äh Ehepartner und alles was laufen kann
zusammenkommt um dann
Vorweihnachtszeit irgendwie Zeit
miteinander zu verbringen ja es gibt ja
auch also da wenn man jetzt in die in
die Straße geht z.B hinter der Deutschen
Bank da ist eine Kita da sindmer
deutsche bankkinder drin ja also das ist
schon so quasi die werden schon geformt
da können die gerade laufen
das war jetzt ein bisschen bös bös
gesagt aber also es gibt dann ein sehr
engen sehr engen Zusammenhalt und ich
habe auch dann meine man macht man auch
Veranstaltung mit Kunden ich ich war
meiner Frau auf auf Opernfestivals in in
London nicht als Belohnung für mich oder
Belohnung für meine Frau sondern weil
halt das so organisiert war dass man mit
Kunden und ihren Frauen da hinfuh
ja und das Thema
Abwesenheiten na ja das war zu den
Hauptzeiten großes Thema also ich würde
mal sagen so ein Jahr rechnet man mit
ungefähr 280 Arbeitstagen ich würde mal
sagen die Hälfte davon war ich nicht zu
Hause kann auch sein dass
mehr mein guter haten war dann halt auch
auch entsprechendes Hilfspersonal zu
Hause damit das nicht alles nur an
meiner Frau hängen blieb ja aber es war
war schon so ich w mich ich würde jetzt
nicht so weit gehen dass ich sagen würde
meine Kinder waren mir fremd ist auch
immer eine Frage also die Zeit die man
mit Kindern zubringt die ist ja nicht da
geht's ja weniger um also weniger um die
die die reine Menge an Zeit sondern es
gibt ja auch eine gewisse Qualität von
Zeit ne die man die man
zubringt also 6 Stunden sich neben ein
kleines Kind zu setzen das auf einen ein
RE immer ja Ja Ja zu sagen das ist kann
man auch lassen ja aber ist halt wie man
das macht aber dann kommen wir jetzt
wieder auf ein Thema war es ein guter
Vater war es ein schlechter Vater und so
weiter das sind Dinge die die vermag ich
nicht zu beurteilen die muss man andere
Leute fragen ja also ich ich kann sagen
was ich mir an mir selber beobachtet
habe wie ich das empfunden habe aber ich
kann da nicht stellvertretend für andere
Leute sprechen das geht nicht es wäre
ungerecht ja also die anderen Sachen auf
die du auf die du anspielst da habe ich
keine keine Evidenz keine Anekdote zu
wirklich
nicht machen wir lass lass einfach gut
sein es
reicht ich kann ich kann da ich kann da
nichts ich kann da nicht mehr zu sagen
fertig
[Musik]
die schwere Finanz und Währungskrise in
Südostasien steh im Mittelpunkt der
Konferenz der asianstaaten die BSE in
Hongkong erlebte heute den tiefsten
Abstürzen ihrer Geschichte die domineine
Kippen die BSen
Asiens
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Beispiel Bangkok Hotels Bürokomplexe
schossen in den vergangenen 10 Jahren
nur so in die Höhe doch der bauoom war
mit gelienenem Geld finanziert aus den
USA meist und aus Japan die Geldgeber
wollen nun ihren Einsatz zurück ihr
Glaube an die Boomregion südostasien ist
dahin um 50% ist der Reis innerhalb
weniger Tage teurer geworden kochöl um
mehr als 100% und mit dem Verfall des
Geldes folgen die Pleiten sind Menschen
plötzlich ohne Arbeit in einem Land in
dem schon 40% arbeitslos sind der IWF
hat sich so massiv wie nie in
indonesische Angelegenheit eingemischt
Direktor com des erklärt es gehe jetzt
darum Vertrauen in die Währung und in
die Wirtschaft zurückzugewinnen indem
die Regierung beweist dass sie die
Probleme des Landes erkennt und bereit
ist die notwendigen Maßnahmen für die
Lösung zu ergreifen selbst wenn diese
schwierig und schmerzhaft
sind also damals hat man an diese Sachen
von heute überhaupt nicht gedacht ja
also Länder haben ja einmal die
Möglichkeit über Instrumente ähnlich wie
wie die Bundesrepublik wie
Bundesanleihen Bundesschatzbriefe und
ähnliche Dinge Inland Geld aufzunehmen
und dann gibt's halt auch die
Möglichkeit der der im Ausland Geld
aufzunehmen es gab damals bestimmte
Konstellation sogenannten Euromarkt
wo die Geldaufnahme im Ausland günstiger
war als sich im Land zu finanzieren und
dann ist man halt auf diese Schi
ausgewich aber Länder galten da als also
ich habe ich habe Portugal oder oder
Schweden das das waren da hat keiner in
irgendeiner Form die Bonität
bezweifelt und man darf ja nicht
vergessen es war ja die Zeit weit vom
Euro das heißt die Länder waren ja
letztenendes in ihrer eigenen Währung
unbegrenzt lieferfähig weil sie konnten
drucken so viel sie wollten es gab
natürlich Staatskrisen in 90ern und auch
Staatspleiten
also gab Südkorea es gab
Argentinien
aber nicht nicht nicht nicht so
kernschmelzenartig also das waren keine
malströme die den Rest der Welt mit den
Abgrund gezogen haben weil einfach auch
die die Globalisierung und die die
Verflechtung äh nicht so äh so so eng
war wie
heute da hing nicht da also in 90er hat
ich irgendwie das Gefühl da hing nicht
alles so zusammen und war überschaubarer
also was ich sagen will ist da gab's
dann vier Zahnräder und wenn man da
dreht dann macht unten das andere Rad so
das war ganz überschaubar und
verständlich was da passieren würde wenn
man das macht und heute sind es halt
7500 Zahnräder und du weißt nicht was
passiert wenn du da drehst dann ins
runterfällt es es ist es ist eine völlig
andere Nummer gewesen
damals also wenn ich z.B überlege mit
wie viel Rechtsanwälten ich zu tun hatte
in 90er Jahren und wie viele ich bei
meinen letzten Aktionen gebraucht habe
da das ist mal Faktor 10 ja worau ich
hinaus will ist dass die Bedeutung für
potenzielle Schäden und Kosten aus
schwebenden Rechtsstreiten die wird ja
immer größer und ich glaube einfach dass
wenn man ständig die Renditeerwartung
erhöht und erhöht und erhöht dass dann
automatisch eine Verschiebung des
gesamten Geschäftes im
nicht in die Illegalität sondern in
Richtung Illegalität stattfindet also
man guckt mal kann man das vielleicht
noch machen und dann schreibt man noch
eine kleine Klausel da rein dann geht
das vielleicht noch und so weiter und
das ist einfach so dass dann wenn man
jetzt ganz viele Geschäfte macht und
dieses ganze Geschäftsmodell verschiebt
sich in Richtung Illegalität dann fallen
halt ein paar Geschäfte über die
Klippe das ist was wo Leute auch häufig
eine sehr naive Vorstellung von haben
also ich konstruiere mal ein Fall also
eine Bank es ist ja auch in Deutschland
passiert eine Bank gerät in eine
Liquiditätskrise und wird dann von einer
anderen Bank übernommen und dann haben
die Leute so die Vorstellung ja die
gehen jetzt da rein und wickeln da die
Geschäfte
ab so einfach ist es nicht SN muss ich
einfach vorstellen ich mache einen
Schrank auf und in dem Schrank sind 5000
Aktenordner jeder von den 5000
Aktenordnern hat 1000 Seiten so und
jetzt habe ich dieses eine spezifische
Geschäft das ist vielleicht der dritte
Aktenordner von oben links das will ich
auf jeden Fall loswerden da ist auch
eine gute Zeit für um dieses Geschäft
loszuwerden ich weiß aber nicht ob in
dem zweiten aktenochner der unten links
am Ende steht drin steht dass ich dieses
Geschäft zwischen Januar und März nicht
machen darf oder
so also was ich damit sagen will ist es
kann sein dass diese ganzen Verträge
untereinander aufeinander
verweisen und das muss man sich jetzt
mal einfach als Permutation als
Möglichkeiten vorstellen die einfach
existieren mathematisch die das steigt
ja ins exponentielle und worauf ich
hinaus will ist ich habe hier zwei
Möglichkeiten ich kann mir
ein Rechtsanwalt suchen oder
Rechtsanwälte eine große Kanzlei die
diese ganzen Verträge für mich liest
dann kriege ich von denen rechtliches
Gutachten nach ungefähr drei oder vier
Jahren wenn die die 5 Millionen Seiten
durchgearbeitet haben und ich meine paar
Millionen Gebühren dafür bezahlt habe
kriege ich ein Gutachten da steht dann
drin wahrscheinlich ist es so aber ohne
unsere Haftung das zweite was ich machen
kann ist es selber lesen da fehlt mir im
Zweifel der Sachverstand und das dritte
was ich machen kann ist eine
Entscheidung Unsicherheit treffen und
das ist das was passiert und da gibt's
auch nichts das ist nicht also man liest
dann häufig so dumme Bank oder blödes
Geschäft oder wie kann man so so
bescheuert sein steht of in Medien etwas
anders formuliert aber das ist es ist
einfach so dass die die
über solche Geschäfte Sicherheit zu
erlangen ist schier unmöglich ist schier
unmöglich das heißt ich ich muss mich
auf den Punkt zurückziehen wo ich sage
ich treffe jetzt eine Entscheidung in
Unsicherheit und guck was die
Konsequenzen sind und versuch dann wenn
was schief geh die entsprechenden Dinge
die ich da ausgelöst habe wieder
einzufangen ich behaupte mal einfach
ganz ungeschützt es gibt niemanden der
die Buch die die Rechnungslegung der
Deutschen Bank
versteht ja natürlich gibt's eine
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft die die
Rechnungslegung der Deutschen Bank
versteht aber es gibt keine Einzelperson
die die Rechnungslegung der Deutschen
Bank versteht die gibt's nicht das zu
komplex ja und und
deswegen ist das für mich diese
transparenzfrage ich ich verlange eine
Transparenz über etwas wo ich keine
Transparenz drüber verlangen kann ja das
ist wie die Frage nach der Existenz des
gottesteilchens oder was weiß ich ich
weiß nicht ob es das gibt ja und genauso
weiß ich nicht wo eigentlich der die die
die bis in die letzte verälung hinein
wie diese Industrie funktioniert das
weiß
niemand
[Musik]
also die Banken haben für alles mögliche
Plan B also wenn wenn auf Frankfurt eine
Atombombe fällt dann hat jeder von denen
Plan in der Schublade was sie dann
machen müssen dann weiß jeder wo er
hinlaufen muss wer nach Hause darf und
so weiter und so weiter ja
aber für diese
Finanzkrisen gibt es keinen Plan
[Musik]
B
also man sieht hier in dem
Geschäftsbericht von der UBS ein Punkt
zum Thema Rückstellung
eventualverpflichtungen das sind in der
Formulierung von der UBS UBS nimmt nach
nimmt für Verfahren Rückstellung also
Gerichtsverfahren Rückstellungen vor
wenn die Geschäftsleitung nach erfolgter
rechtlicher Beratung zur Auffassung
gelangt dass der Bestand einer
Zahlungsverpflichtung wahrscheinlich ist
und der Höhe der Zahlung zuverlässig
abgeschätzt werdenn kan und dann gibt's
jetzt hier für jede von diesen ganzen
Dingen hier gibt's also diese diese
Erklärungen ja da gibt's ein Verfahren
über gemeindeanleihen dann haben wir die
leeman principal protection Notes das
sind schlicht einfach Wertpapiere die
von Lehman ausgegeben worden sind die
hat die UBS an Leute verkauft und wird
jetzt offensichtlich verklagt dass sie
das verkauft hat und nicht hätte g
machen dürfen dann haben wir klagen im
Zusammenhang mit dem Verkauf von
residential morgetback securrities in
Hypotheken das ist ein großer Posten das
sind die Hypotheken in USA die die die
sogenannten schrotthypotheken die
verkauft worden sind dann geht zum
Offenlegungspflichten dann gibt's ja den
Bernard medof ein ein ja
Verurteilten Anlagebetrüger mit dem die
UBS wohl auch zusammen war Transaktion
mit der Stadt Mailand und Einheiten des
öffentlichen Sektors Italien da hatten
wir schon
diese die kommunal Swaps sind das also
die Zinswetten von Kommunen dann haben
wir die HSH Bank in in Hamburg und
Hannover die
gegen UBS klag weil sie was verkauft hat
was sie nicht hätte kaufen sollen dann
gibt's die kommunalen wesserwerke
Leipzig GmbH puto Rico ja dann ist sie
ein ganzes Kapitel Libor das ist ja ein
Kapitel das gerade abgeschlossen worden
ist seitens der US durch eine nicht
unbeträchtlich war wie viel war das C
1,5 Milliarden Dollar so die größ
machen das Interessante ist halt Sachen
nie auf ein Institut begrenzt sind also
es würde mich sehr sehr wundern wenn
irgendwo sag mal irgend Skandal in Bezug
auf ein Produkt hochpppt und das würde
keinen anderen betreffen das wäre sehr
merkwürdig dazu ist die Branche zu stark
vernetzt also ich kann mich an ein
Produkt erinnern ich will das jetzt
nicht näher erläutern weil es erstens
irrelevant ist und zweitens zu
kompliziert aber ich kann mich an ein
meiner Arbeitgeber erinnern da mach rund
um uns rum machten Banken so ein neues
Produkt und dieses Produkt da waren wir
uns eigentlich mit ein paar Leuten einig
die davon was verstanden das ist
komplett das war komplett
schwachsinnig also hat extreme Risiken
gehabt sehr wenig Ertrag hohe Aufwand zu
produzieren also wirklich alles was man
nicht
braucht und wir sind dann letztenendes
doch als letzte auf diesen Wagen
aufgesprungen weil irgendeiner von den
obersten Bossen hatte in der Zeitung
gelesen da machen die das und die machen
das und die machen dieo machen wir das
nicht ja und dann setzt so eine
kollektive Panik ein um dann quasi so
mit einem Rad durch die Kurve so ein
Produkt auf die Straße stellen statt zu
sagen lass die anderen machen wir sind
der Meinung und wir verstehen mehr davon
als die anderen das war in dem Fall so
das kann nicht funktionieren ja und was
jetzt passiert das hat also 4 f Jahre
gebraucht um sich zu entwickeln also ich
rede über 2004 glaube ich war das war so
die Phase als dieses Produkt kreiert
wurde und jetzt so nach vier 5 se Jahren
explodieren die
Dinger wir haben hier die beiden echten
badbangs das ist die die Gesellschaft
für Wertmanagement und die erste
abwiungsanstalt Hypo Real Estate und
WestLB hier haben wir die restructuring
unit der
Commerzbank die soweit ich weiß
onbalance ist die Eurohypo existiert
noch als normale Bank das ist jetzt
nicht
notwendigerweise apostrophierte badbank
und die HSH Nordbank ist die ist
in
Landesbank die offensichtlich auch
irgendwo unbalance 58 Milliarden als als
ja notleid Kredite oder
abwicklungskredite gekennzeichnet
hat die interessante Frage wird dann wo
der Verlust anfällt aber ich wenn ich
mir das jetzt da angucke also die
Kommerzbank und die Eurohypo muss man
kann man quasi
zusammenrechnen Staatsbeteiligung 25% h
real estate 100% erste abflungsanstalt
100% HSA
100%. also die einzigen die einzigen die
eventuell bluten müssen sind die 75%
restaktionäre der Kommerzbank über Start
hinaus ansonsten sind die Steuerzahler
mit
dabei würde ich das meinen Kindern
erklären das ist wie wenn man faulen
Apfel aus dem obskorb
nimmt der der faule Apfel ist dann zwar
immer noch da und dann kann man halt
gucken ob man den durchschneidet und
noch essen kann oder ob der ganz
vergammelt
sozusagen ich meine ich verstehe warum
das so sein muss aber wie schnell diese
Entscheidungsprozesse funktionieren dass
man über über ein paar hundert Millionen
in im in der Kultur sich jahrelang
streitet aber für eine Bankenrettung mal
eben 100 oder 200 Milliarden über ein
Wochenende das geht das ist schon
irgendwie
faszinierend
[Musik]
der Druck auf Angela Merkel wächst
griechenland braucht wohl noch mehr Geld
wenn dieser Gipfel nichts ordentliches
gegen die Schuldenkrise zustande bringt
dann wird die ganze Eurozone
herabgestuft so die Drohung des Rating
riesen
standardours auf so unverblümte Weise
ist Politikern von der Finanzwelt wo
noch nie die Pistole auf die Brust
gesetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wen
[Musik]
in Griechenland ging es ja darum dass
auf keinen Fall auf keinen Fall ein
Bankrott von Griechenland eintreten
durfte darum ging es ja und jetzt gibt's
halt bei den griechischen Anleihen zwei
verschiedene Systeme es gibt einmal
Anleihen nach international meist recht
und es gibt Anleihen nach griechischem
Recht der Unterschied ist der dass bei
diesem griechischen Recht kann der Staat
letztenendes ja bestimmen ihr kriegt
nicht mehr für 1000 € 1000 € wieder
sondern nur noch 4000 das ist ja auch so
passiert und nach englischem Recht ist
es so dass es eine Gläubiger Versammlung
geben muss und die beschließt darüber ob
dieser Vergleich angenommen wird oder
nicht das heißt wenn ich jetzt als hgef
hergehe und kaufe von 100 Millionen bei
75 Millionen z.B dann habe ich eine
qualifizierte Mehrheit für die
Abstimmung und dann kann ich den
Griechen sagen wisst ihr was entweder er
gibt uns die Kohle oder wir lassen das
Ding hops gehen und dann seid ihr
technisch im
Bankrott aber so operieren die also die
versuchen letztenendes dir so viel Ärger
zu machen die versuchen mit allen
Mitteln ihr Rechtsansprüche
durchzusetzen bis du irgendwann sagst
weiß du wie scheiß 20 Millionen diese
Zecke im Pelz
ja und dann zahlt man und dann haben die
gewonnen das ist ein Geschäftsmodell
gewesen mit den griechenanleihen es gab
gezielte Aufkäufe in diesen Anleihen
nach internationalem Recht da muss halt
gucken da gibt's halt gibt halt eine
Liste mit S mal ich habe keine Ahnung
wie viel anlihen Griechen draußen haben
500 700 000 keine Ahnung aber da kannst
du halt über über eine Datenbank
raussuchen welche sind nach englischem
Recht und welche sind nach griechischem
Recht re schmeißt du weg so dann hast du
vielleicht 50 oder 70 oder 100 nach
englischem Recht und dann gehst du her
und guckst und sagst wie viel Geld habe
ich wie stehen die ja du brauchst ja
wenn du jetzt überlegst wenn die Dinger
wenn die Dinger bei bei sagen wir mal
30% stehen ja statt 100 und du willst
von 100 Millionen 75 Millionen kaufen
also die stimm du brauchst ja 75% der
Stimmrechte ja dann hast du nur noch von
30 Millionen 75% das heißt du kaufst für
28 Millionen deine Stimmrechte für 100
Millionen anle das ist dann letztenendes
auch dein Gewinn also du zahlst 28
Millionen zwingst den ST 100 Millionen
auszuzahlen das lohnt schon mal
ja so macht man das das war das war das
war ein ganz normales ganz normales
geschäsm das hat nicht nur eine das hat
nicht nur eine Firma gemacht
ja das sind solche Geldsummen unterwegs
mit denen man wirklich inzwischen auch
Länder angab greifen
kN man fängt halt mit dem kleinsten Land
an
Griechenland und da sieht man dann halt
wie die Einheit EU reagiert und man
schafft ein gewisses wie soll ich sagen
man knackst das Eis ein bisschen an
sozusagen und dann nimmt man sich das
nächst größere Land in dem Fall Portugal
dann kriegt das Eis schon wieder mehr
Resse es gibt ja Leute die Interesse
daran haben dass der Euro zerbricht ein
gigantisches Gewinnpotenzial was da drin
steckt ja ähm und äh das äh da geht da
gibt's auch sicherlich Leute die
politisches Interesse daran haben dass
der Euro zerbricht
ähm und dann das das würde man so machen
dass man im Prinzip die ja mir fällt
jetzt ein schlechtes Beispiel ein aber
wie gesagt dass man sich die die
schwächste Stelle sucht da anknackst und
dann quasi das Ganze nach außen
aufbricht ich war jetzt gerade in
Spanien
ähm das ist schon echt bitter echt
bitter die Leute sind wirklich
verzweifelt man sieht wie das Angebot im
Supermarkt zurückgeht und das bestimmte
Sachen nicht mehr passieren also W man
z.B irgendwie eine bestimmte Menge an an
Baumaterial bestellt sein es Fliesen
oder irgendwelche Mauersteine oder sowas
die werden nicht mehr geliefert weil
einfach von A nach B fährt kein
Lastwagen für eine kleine Kiste Fliesen
und mehr wird dann nicht
bestellt
das klingt jetzt alles komisch aber das
das ist
wirklich langsames zerbröseln der
gesamten gesellschaftlichen
Infrastruktur weil keine Kaufkraft mehr
da ist wenn keine Kaufkraft mehr da ist
wird nicht mehr wird nicht mehr
gehandelt wenn nicht mehr gehandelt wird
findet weniger Verkehr
statt das das ist wie so ein Domino
diese Dominosteine die umfallen und wenn
man da regelmäßig
hinfährt was was ich tue dann merkt man
einfach jedes mal so ein bisschen mehr
wie wie das Land
zerbröselt und die Leute sich versuchen
irgendwelche subsistenzexistenzen
aufzubauen und da wo sie früher Blümchen
im Garten hatten da sind plötzlich
irgendwelche Kartoffeln oder sowas das
ist schon merk
spürbar bei den staten muss man genau
sehen wo hat eigentlich dieses
Verschuldung Problem seinen Ursprung die
gesamte Immobilienkrise die eigentlich
Spanien Abgrund gerissen hat über das
Bankensystem multipliziert also
verstärkt ist ja eine Krise der
Verschuldung der privaten Haushalte das
ist ja keine Krise der Verschuldung der
Staatshaushalte was liches steht uns
jetzt in Holland bevor wo eine ähnliche
Situation ist über die allerdings keiner
gerne
spricht das muss man sich mal vorstellen
Holland hat wenn ich die Zahl richtig im
Kopf habe
120% des Bruttosozialprodukts als
Verschuldung im
mobilenektor
nur Immobilien das ist
Privatverschuldung also die
Staatsverschuldung die interessiert
eigentlich gar keinen weil weil alleine
die Privatverschuldung überschreitet
schon die die die die Grenze die man
normalerweise für Staatsschulden als
angemessen ansieht wenn plötzlich 30%
der niederländischen Bevölkerung ihre
ihre Schulden nicht mehr bezahlen können
auf ihre Häuser halte ich das für sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass der
Gerichtsvollzieher kommt und setzt die
auf die
Straße also da wird dann irgendwie eine
Lösung gefunden werden so wie man in
Spanien jetzt anfängt mit diesen
Zwangsräumung zurückzugehen und und
aufzupassen dass es nicht ausufert weil
es einfach linke Tasche rechte Tasche
ist du hast die Leute direkt quasi in
den Sozialkassen da kann ja auch keiner
Interesse dran
haben was muss man erwarten als nächstes
Frankreich Frankreich
ähm das ist einfach
wirtschaftlich ein wirkliches Problem
was die da haben
ähm und die die Strukturreformen die
nötig sind werden nicht angegangen
stattdessen macht man ich bin jetzt kein
Feind von Steuern aber man macht da eine
völlig wilde
Steuerpolitik also ich glaube Frankreich
war zu ein
Problem und dann aber es ist einfach
dann ist vorbei dann ist
aus Game
Over deswegen deswegen versucht man ja
so so verzweifelt bei Spanien und
Italien flöcker einzuziehen das ist ja
eine Kette die sich ergeben hat ne
Griechenland Griechenland Portugal
Spanien Italien das immer das nächst
größere Land dann
Frankreich das ist tja wenn Frankreich
in in so eine Situation kommt dann sind
das Beträge die die die die EZB die kann
keiner mehr schultern hier das kann man
knicken da muss man sich was einfallen
lassen das fliegt uns irgendwann um die
Ohren und entweder fliegt uns finanz
technisch um die Ohren oder
gesellschaftspolitisch um die Ohren aber
das das ein gutes Ende kriegt das glaube
ich keine
Sekunde
ich bin entlassen worden letzten Endes
ja ich bin jetzt auch in ein Alter wo im
Prinzip alle die um mich rum waren die
werden langsam ausgefaced ne also bis
zur Rente arbeitet da kein
Mensch
das ist auch so dass die Unternehmen
dann in der Regel wirklich freundliche
Regelung haben keine Boni aber Deal
kriegst noch 5
jah du ziehst al das Schnitt hier nach
unten 53 54 55 das war's
dann
das findet ja ständig statt ja Leute
gehen weg weil sie ein besseren Job
haben Leute fliegen raus weil sie
irgendein Scheiß gebaut haben das ist
eine andere Sache wenn so Wellen Rollen
also wenn jetzt irgendwie gesagt worden
ist das passiert ja gern so gegen Ende
des Jahres dann wird gesagt so wir bauen
jetzt mal hier schön 4000 Stellen ab
davon 800 da und da und dann weißt du
ungefähr wie viele Leute da sitzen
welcher Bereich betroffen ist und dann
ist das so ein bisschen so wie so eine
frontkampagie im Ersten Weltkrieg ne so
wer sitzt noch im Schützengraben da gibt
so Leute die sich wirklich dann auch
ganz bewusst wegducken ja die sitzen
plötzlich vor an dass man sie gar nicht
mehr sehen kann in so einer Ecke ein
bisschen
albern aber dann dann dann ist es schon
so dass man irgend im Prinzip so
überlegt wann bin ich denn dran ne so
das ist eine
durchaus präsenteer Angst es war früher
nicht so das war früher nicht so da sind
auch Leute rausgeflogen und dann wurden
auch Leute eingestellt und so aber diese
dieses ja
nahkriegserlebnis
ich das das das das gab's in der Form
nicht aber das ist natürlich wird
natürlich auch zu dem Management
Instrument ne weil
die
die da dadurch ein Druck erzeugt wird
ich hatte malinen Chef der war
columbianer der hat gesagt bei bei mir
in der Abteilung jedes ja 10% der Leute
raus dann weißt Du genau du hast maximal
Jahre stört dich das dass wir da jetzt
drüber sprechen oder nee ich ich weiß
nur nicht
warum Du immer versuchst noch mehr
rauszukriegen ich habe ich ich erzähle
das so wie ich das kann und es gibt da
nicht mehr Details drüber zu reden also
das
ist ja ich habe gesagt es tut weh klar
tut weh logisch ja und der Prozess der
läuft halt so ab wie abläuft also es
wird eine Familie geschaffen die dich
einnimmt und reinzieht und die Art und
Weise wie du aber hinten aus der Familie
ausgeschieden wird passt gar nicht dazu
zu diesem familiengedanke was sie am
Anfang irgendwie als Spiegel oder als
als Option dargestellt wird nicht ja das
ist richtig das heißt die Familie hat ja
nie existiert nö du hast Zeit deines
Lebens an eine Familie geglaubt die dich
am Schluss h durch die Hintertür
rauschmeißt
ja aber die
die das ist ich hatte vorhin den
Vergleich zwischen Söldner und Sterben
fürs Vaterland da ist halt für jeden was
dabei ich muss das Gefühl haben geliebt
zu werden von so einem von so einer
Institution soweit das möglich ist ja
und und und gewertschätzt zu werden und
dann ist es natürlich umso schlimmer
wenn der quasi auf diese Art der Teppich
unterm Boden weggezogen wird ja dem
Söldner um bei dem Beispiel zu bleiben
dem tut das nicht weh dem sch
egal also ich würde das fast als
normalen Zyklus bezeichnen das ist halt
am Anfang eine Euphorie dann wird man
wie von dieser Welle weggespült und dann
schwimmst und schwimmst und schwimmst
und irgendwann kommt der
Kater
ja und dann habe ich halt eben Hölle in
Bewegung gesetzt um wieder einen neuen
Job zu kriegen der so ähnlich ist oder
besser wie der den ich
hatte da muss ich im Nachhinein sagen
aber das sage ich
heute das war genau der entscheidende
Schritt zu viel also das war eine das
war eine Situation wo ich das Gefühl
hatte ich habe eigentlich meine Würde
verloren das war das nicht sein
müssen also man braucht sehr sehr lange
um sagen wir mal ein ein unvorstellten
Blick auf das Ganze zu
werfen und
äh bei bei den meisten Leuten auch bei
denen die ihren Job verlieren z.B steht
eigentlich an
oberster Stelle wie kriege ich jetzt den
selben Job so schnell wie möglich
wieder und nicht die Frage ähm gibt es
ein Lebensmodell dass ich mir eigentlich
immer schon erträumt habe
und jetzt habe ich eine Chance das mal
auszuprobieren sondern es ist eigentlich
dieses
dieses innerhalb der gewohnten
Bahnen WE da zu machen und das ist
natürlich ein Problem in einer Industrie
die so stark schrumpft in speziellen
Bereichen wie jetzt die Finanzindustrie
ich glaube da werden noch viele tja äh
geistig stark deformierten Leute
irgendwie äh auf der Strecke bleiben ja
weil die mit
dem mit dem mit der
eigenverantwortlichen Gestaltung
ähm außerhalb dieses Systems äh
überfordert sind
ja
woran liegt es dass man den Banken nicht
mehr
vertraut manche Banken sagen das liegt
an den Krisen andere an den Börsen wir
haben etwas getan was für uns bisher
vielleicht nicht typisch war wir haben
die Gründe bei uns gesucht und uns
gefragt braucht Deutschland noch eine
Bank die einfach so
weitermacht
oder brauchen wir eine Bank die endlich
Schluss macht mit neuen Spekulationen
auf Grundnahrungsmittel eine Bank die
erneuerbare Energien für die Zukunft
finanziert eine Bank die auch kleinen
und mittleren Unternehmen Kredite gibt
eine Bank die ihre Berater nicht belohnt
wenn sie möglichst viele Verträge
verkaufen sondern erst dann wenn Ihre
Kunden zufrieden
sind vor uns liegt ein langer Weg aber
auch der beginnt mit dem ersten
Schritt
ich habe nicht den Eindruck dass ich in
diesem System von innen irgendwas tut
alle starren wie gebannt auf die Politik
und auf die Regulatoren und sagen sagt
uns doch was wir machen sollen
eigentlich weiß jeder genau was von dir
erwartet wird sie machen es
nicht stattdessen werden Anzeigen
geschaltet wo halt drin steht wir haben
verstanden oder ja irgendwelche riesen
corporate Corporate Identity Broschüren
und
Corporate Responsibility Broschüren
gemacht ja das ist das ist auch sowas
was was man beobachtet ich habe mich ja
mit philantthropie beschäftigt und das
ist corporate Respons social Corporate
Social Responsibility ist ein wichtiger
Teil davon also quasi die die Spenden
und und sozialen Aktionen die
Unternehmen machen ja und was also was
ich beobachten kann und da haut jetzt
wahrscheinlich wieder ein paar Leute vom
Schlitten der das besser wissen als ich
aber je größer die Scheiße ist desto
dicker sind die Corporate Social
Responsibility brochchüren
ja ich finde gut dass Aktionen ergriffen
werden ich halte die ganzen Dinge die
getan worden sind sind auch im Rahmen
der Entscheidungsfindung in der Politik
für sinnvoll ich bin nur der festen
Überzeugung sie werden nicht erziel
erreichen sie werden nicht der Ziel
erreichen also ein Gesetz ist in sechs
Monaten gemacht und 150 Milliarden für
eine Bankenrettung sind in SE Monaten
verabschiedet aber die das das Denken in
den Köpfen der Leute das ja auch wieder
eine Reflektion einer gesellschaftlichen
Situation ist das zu ändern das ist ein
dekadenprojekt das langt kein Politiker
an selbst wenn man anguckt welche
Semantik heute benutzt wird die Märkte
es gibt nicht die Märkte wir tun so als
wäre das irgendine gotthafte Kraft die
über uns h
reinbricht die Bank oder die Firma hat
entschieden nein da entscheiden
Menschen und wenn man den Menschen sagt
hör damit auf dann hören die damit auf
das muss man nur in richtigen Art
tun und wenn z.B ein ein Chef von einer
großen Investmentbank morgen E-Mail
rausschickt wo drin steht jeder Händler
der noch Shorts hat in Spanien Portugal
egal was also gegen diese staten
spekuliert der fliegt am nächsten Tag
raus dann ist sofort Schluss damit da
müssen natürlich auch noch andere
Beteiligte mitmachen nicht Banken und so
weiter aber wenn der Wille dazu da wäre
dann wäre das so als würde man
wasserhand zudrehen und warum passiert's
nicht
weil niemals einer mit irgendwas
anfängt braucht ein Bruch ja mit
Sicherheit braucht's den aber da
braucht's ja entweder ein externen
Schock also sprich
politische Eingriffe oder noch eine
Krise ja
ähm oder es braucht irg irgendeinen
radikalinski der der in der Lage ist mit
einem neuen Geschäftsmodell überzeugend
darzustellen das funst das funktioniert
ja der Schock war doch groß genug
gerade
nein
nein also das das kann das können nur
Naivlinge glauben dass dass der Markt
lernfähig ist wer hatten das Thema
können Banken lernen das ist eine Frage
kollektives
wividuelles lernen aber die Antwort ist
nein nein Märkte lernen auch nicht
Investoren lernen auch
nicht die springen die springen die
springen in genau denselben Abgrund ind
dem sie indem sie vor zwei jahrench Mal
gesprungen sind oder geschubst worden
sind da springen s heute mit Freude
rein da kann man viele Beispiele machen
bis zurück in die 30er Jahre das ist
nee da glaube ich nicht dran also auf
die Frage war der Schock groß genug klar
war ein großer
Schock let's get on with
[Musik]
it
[Applaus]
[Musik]
züte
se
deen
lass
beschwi
al lass
gchen nicht
deine
Hut
[Musik]
erfreu
de H lass
mich er
[Musik]
fre
[Gelächter]
[Musik]